but i guess like you know wedding aside
it was like i guess it was like
a
reasonable amount of time in the uk you
i feel like you got to experience more
of the uk this time as well yeah
absolutely yeah i mean last time i was
in the uk which was the first time was
we were staying mostly at your place in
brighton yeah so i think we were only in
london for maybe like
two days yeah even then it was mostly
just like going to all of the you know
touristy places yeah right so i think
yeah this time around not only did i get
to have like a proper
like view of london london yeah but also
like chris took me out of london as well
to like we went filming into a bunch of
places and i actually got to see like
the countryside of london i got to see
stonehenge oh did you actually yeah we
went to stone edge it's really
disappointing isn't it yeah
it looks way cooler from a disney yeah
because you actually get so to get to
stonehenge you have to like go to this
visitor center buy a ticket for some
[ __ ] reason yeah and then you can
either take a bus
which is like five minutes to stonehenge
or you can walk across the fields for
like 30 minutes yeah and i was like well
it's kind of a nice day let's just like
walk across the fields because it might
be nice yeah it was not nice
because it was not only nothing yeah for
30 minutes but there was also just horse
[ __ ] everywhere
so i'm like [ __ ] dodging these like
you know these [ __ ] horse this horse
[ __ ] because god forbid these are the
only pair of [ __ ] shoes i have as
well so i don't want your besties i was
wearing the besties
no i have to wear these for the wedding
i'm not having
these right so we got to it and then
i guess because there was like an
incident uh some years ago of like some
drawing you know uh you know [ __ ] on the
stone here
yeah yeah so they had actually like
fenced it off yeah but like they had
fenced it off not really like an arms
reach away but like at least about a
hundred meters away yeah so the closest
you could get to stonehenge was like 100
meters away
which
was kind of like defeating the purpose i
guess like because apparently you used
to be able to like actually walk into
stonehenge and they actually get like a
view of it you can't do that anymore
because i guess some people just ruined
it for everyone so
which you know was like kind of
underwhelming i guess in a sense but
like you know i was like well you know
stonehenge is like that one uh heritage
site that you hear people talking about
and it's like a hot tourist place so i'm
just like well you know what at least
now i can say that i've seen stonehenge
but like
it was
fascinating necessarily not really i'd
go to a greg's any day over stonehenge
yeah i mean we did afterwards
we went to greg's afterwards but like i
think the most enjoyment i had like on
that trip out of london was the fact
that like i just actually got to see
like the real side of the uk like the
actual like country side like we went
past like all these like really small
like quaint little villages that you are
like there were some villages that we
drove past that legitimately looked like
rpgs
it was it was like an rpg like medieval
town which was like so [ __ ] cool most
of the uk right but like i've never seen
that before right because my experience
of the uk is london and brighton right
which is very much not like that yeah so
it was really cool to actually like stop
by in like these really small quaint
villages to be like oh we got like the
full experience of the uk one of the
best one of the best [ __ ] stories
was we stopped by uh i had i was like
dying for a piss right right and so i
was like we have to stop by somewhere
right yeah and like we're in the middle
of nowhere right so we're like oh okay i
guess we'll just like stop by the
closest village to see if there's like
an establishment right we can borrow um
so we stopped by this village i don't
even remember the name of this village
it's [ __ ] tiny and
we got to the entrance of the village
and there's like this old dude standing
there and he like kind of flags us down
like hey yeah and so chris is like all
right this uh what what's what's
happening and we drive up to him and
he's like yeah what's what's the problem
and the guy goes are you here to see the
duck race
and we're like what
it's like there's a duck race happening
so make sure to drive nice and slowly
across this road okay
a dark race
and sure enough we drop we drive maybe
about 50 meters and there's just this
gathering of about
10 to 20 like old people just watching
these ducks
that sounds awesome and i'm like this is
the most british thing i've ever seen in
my [ __ ] life what else are you gonna
do with your free time yeah yeah and i
was like i want to be there yeah in the
at that age i want to just like wake up
in the morning and be like oh the duck
races today and just go down to my local
pond and just watch some ducks
that's [ __ ] awesome yeah yeah it's
cause like
i remember like as like we went to a pub
the day for a wedding yeah um and it was
like it's very very quaint local pub uh
in this very very small town yeah um
because this this like where the wedding
took place it was in a town that was
like you know you could walk from one
end to the other in about like 30
minutes
it was a [ __ ] tiny so it was like a
local pub and like i remember there was
just this poster on the wall that just
said uh this is the place for the uh the
worldwide annual pea tossing tournament
or something like that oh yeah well it
was the p flicking tournament right well
i think it's the way that the streets
had kind of uh the way like that natural
landscape was yeah the idea was that you
threw at the peaks i googled it so i was
curious yeah i'm gonna throw the p i
mean this is gonna tell him wherever
your wedding is by the way yeah it's
only in this place i mean i mean
i already have one wedding yeah
so so the way that this kind of town is
really cool architecture it's like kind
of like there's a village at the top and
then it kind of winds down yeah towards
the bottom so the idea of this pea
throwing thing apparently according to
google is it the idea is that you throw
it and hopefully if you throw it well
enough or kind of lucky it'll kind of
bounce around the walls and kind of go
all the way down oh my people will like
follow it and and makes and see where
they're right it goes which i think that
sounds pretty [ __ ] difficult that
sounds [ __ ] fun it's also extremely
brilliant that's really british but
that's fun yeah so uh you met my parents
for the first time oh yeah that was fun
and uh yeah connor came around to my
house uh a few days before the wedding
we had like a nice meal together
um and
connor connor met my parents
for the first time i got out of the car
and i was wearing a hat and i met your
dad and i was like oh hi hi and he's
like oh hi hi i go inside and then your
mom sees me oh my god it's connor
she was like i watch you all the time i
was like oh
oh yeah hell yeah
she's just like really sweet and she
gave me a hug and she was like oh my god
i i always watch you on the tv it's so
nice you know it's
so awesome it was really wholesome yeah
and then she like whipped up like the
best food i'd ever had yeah just amazing
it was really good food yeah but there
was there was one moment well i can't
remember if it was when uh when when
uh when she first met you or when you
were having food or something
but i remember she was like talking to
you
and then she's like not she's like never
really mentioned to me about like any of
our content aside from like what we've
talked about and everything like that
yeah
so so she's like never mentioned this to
me before but like i remember she turns
to connor and she's like you should have
won the cycling special and i'm like
what the [ __ ] mom everyone knows that
everyone knows [ __ ] i was like i got
betrayed by my own [ __ ] family i was
i was like she's never ever mentioned
the cycling special for me before at all
aside from like oh it looks like a
really beautiful place you guys were too
but no like i was like i was like
[ __ ] i i'm
and then i think your dad then realized
who i was yeah because he'd said hi to
me but he'd like didn't and then i think
when your mom had said that he was like
oh it's oh he's that guy
he was oh it's connor it's connor hi hi
and i was like oh okay
all right okay
it's really nice it's really sweet
yeah how was your experience back in
england because yeah it was kid i mean
it's it's it's like you know you know
how it is it's like going back
hey i'm back
let's do it yeah uh it was weird seeing
some things had changed kind of a little
bit like uh i don't know it was uh it
was interesting this time because it was
very like full on this time yeah every
single day there was something happening
yeah but that was good i like that
because i kind of hate it when i'm like
kind of like not doing anything and i'm
like just wandering around yeah what am
i gonna do today what am i gonna eat
because what am i gonna eat is so
important
yeah like i was actually like really
much happier with like the food that i
had there like that was so [ __ ] good
yeah i don't know if like the food
quality just improved or we just went to
like better restaurants i don't know i
felt it felt like there were more food
options in my trip back to england this
time right i mean just go to borough
market in london best [ __ ] food in
london yes
every restaurant there goes
unequivocally hard yeah
i spent like an afternoon in the borough
markets with a friend of mine from high
school and it was [ __ ] awesome yeah
so cool dude the cheese there yeah
good [ __ ] dude yeah yeah